that talk
in your thinking here is not literally
referring to a simulation in that our
our universe is a kind of computer
program running in a computer
it's more of a thought experiment um
do you also think of the potential of
the sort of
bostrom elon musk
and others that talk about an actual
program
that simulates our universe oh i don't
doubt that we're in a simulation
i just think that it's not quite that
important
i mean i'm interested only in simulation
theory as far as like it gives me power
over nature
uh if it's totally unfalsifiable then
who cares
i mean what do you think that experiment
would look like like somebody
on twitter asked ask george what signs
we would look for to know whether or not
we're in the simulation
which is exactly what you're asking is
like
the step that precedes the step of
knowing how to get more power
from this knowledge is to get an
indication that there's some power to be
gained so
get an indication that there you can
discover
and exploit cracks in the simulation or
it doesn't have to be you know
in the physics of the universe yeah
show me i mean like a memory leak would
be cool
like some scrying technology you know
what what kind of technology
scrying what's that oh that's a weird uh
this crying is the
is the uh paranormal ability to uh
like like remote viewing like being able
to see somewhere where you're not
um so you know i don't think you can do
it by chanting in a room but
um if we could find as a memory leak
basically
yeah you're able to access parts you're
not supposed to yeah yeah yeah and
thereby discover a shortcut
yeah maybe memory leak means the other
thing as well but i mean like yeah like
an ability to read arbitrary memory
yeah right um and that one's not that
horrifying right the the right ones
start to be horrifying read
right so the reading is not the problem
yeah
it's like heartbleed for the universe oh
boy the writing is a big big problem
it's a big problem it's the moment you
can write anything even if it's just
random noise that's terrifying
i mean even without even without that
like even some of the you know the nano
tech stuff that's coming i think
you